>> WELL, THAT'S GAME OVER FOR
ME.
WANT TO WATCH TV LATER?
>> SOUNDS GOOD.
>> SEE YOU LATER.
>> OKAY.
>> HEY, ADAM.
PLAYING A VIDEO GAME?
>> YES, I LOVE IT.
>> TONIGHT I'M MAKING
MARGARITAS.
>> PERFECT.
ADAM AND I ARE WATCHING LATER.
>> WHAT?
WHY IS THIS THE FIRST TIME I'M
HEAR BEING THIS.
I HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON.
WE NEED TO TALK.
>> I HAVE NO ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA
WHAT HE IS WANTING TO TALK
ABOUT.
I'M PLAYING MY VIDEO GAME.
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> I WAS GOING TO MAKE
MARGARITAS FOR JUST YOU AND ME
AND NOW THE TV THING WITH RYAN?
I GUESS I'M CONFUSED.
>> I SORT OF FORGOT ABOUT
MARGARITA NIGHT.
>> EXCUSE ME?
ADAM WAS ONE OF THE ONLY GUYS IN
THE HOUSE I CAN TRUST AND HE
FORGETS ABOUT MARGARITA NIGHT?
NOW I REALLY HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> YOU FORGOT?
>> I'M SORRY.
ARE WE STILL COOL?
>> I GUESS.
WE ARE.
I'M REALLY PROUD OF YOU FOR
TELLING ME THE TRUTH.
>> ALEX AND I ARE COOL AGAIN.
HE'S QUICKLY BECOMING ONE OF MY
FAVORITE GUYS IN THE HOUSE.
>> HEY, HEY.
I'M READY FOR TV TIME WITH MY
MAIN MAN, ADAM.
I MADE PINA COLADAS.
WAIT.
ALEX?
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, MAY I
INTRODUCE TO YOU, DRAMA.
>> CAN WE TALK?
>> IS ANYONE GOING TO EXPLAIN TO
ME WHAT THE HELL IS GOING ON?
>> LET ME EXPLAIN TO YOU WHAT'S
GOING ON HERE.
>> FINALLY, SOME ANSWERS.
I'M LISTENING, PEOPLE.
>> WHAT HAPPENED EARLIER THAT I
THINK YOU SHOULD KNOW ABOUT.
>> I'M MAKING MARG REIT AS.
>> FORGOT ABOUT MARGARITA NIGHT.
>> YOU WERE GOING TO MAKE
MARGARITAS.
>> YEP.
NOW THAT I SEE THAT YOU HAVE
MADE PINA COLADAS, WE NEED TO
HAVE A CHIT-CHAT.
>> OKAY.
NO COMMENT.
>> I'M STAYING OUT OF THIS.
>> I THINK YOU NEED SOME
PRIVACY.
>> THE REASON I WANTED TO TALK
TO YOU IS I WANT TO CANCEL
MARGARITA NIGHT AND I WANT TO
KNOW IF YOU WILL MAKE ME A PINA
COLADA.
>> REALLY?
>> THE ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION
IS -- NO.
BECAUSE IT'S ALREADY MADE.
THERE IS EXTRA LEFT IN THE
BLENDER.
I'M GOING TO POUR SOME FOR YOU
NOW.
>> AS WE RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
SEATTLE, SEASON 6,000.
>> APPROXIMATE ARE SAY WHAT?
>> FIRST THE MARGARITAS AND NOW
THIS.
THAT'S WHY THEY CALL IT THE
HOUSE.
>> WELCOME TO MY AWKWARD LIFE.